la fortune des casinos fait aussi
tourner la tête des Indiens eux-mêmes
aujourd'hui l'ennemi le plus redoutable
vient de l'intérieur des tribus la
distribution des dividendes du jeu
déchire les Indiens
pour le comprendre il faut aller en
Californie
l'état où il y a le plus de casino
indiens en tout 57 établissements
direction la tribu des reading rancheria
à deux heures de route de Sacramento
une tribu de 250 membres massacré par
les chercheurs d'or au XIXe siècle
[Musique]
Dino ont bouleversé la vie des formats
en 2004 les 75 membres de la famille
sont exclus de la tribu et chacun perd
ses 3000 dollars mensuel de dividendes
des casinos
depuis toutes les semaines ils viennent
se recueillir sur les tombes de leur
grand-mère et arrière-grand-mère
[Musique]
en 2004 pour tenter de prouver qu'ils
étaient indiens et membre de la tribu
ils ont été obligés de commettre un
sacrilège ils ont déterré leurs deux
ancêtres
[Musique]
c'est probablement le jour le plus dur
de ma vie
imaginez un peu on a dû la déterrer
je n'arrive toujours pas à croire que
l'on en soit arrivé là
pour être indien il faut être le
descendant biologique direct d'un membre
de la tribu
depuis le 19e siècle la famille Forman
et membre incontesté de la tribu des
rédings mais en 2002 le Conseil tribal
remet en cause cet appartenance il
affirme que Lorena leur grand-mère a été
adopté et n'est donc pas la fille
biologique de Virginia
l'arrière-grand-mère plus de liens du
sang ils sont exclus de la tribu
après que le Conseil tribal est rejeté
tous les documents prouvant que nous
étions membres de la tribu
ils nous ont dit qu'ils avaient besoin
d'un test ADN
qui veut dire qu'on a dû exhumer ma
grand-mère et mon arrière-grand-mère
en septembre 2003 deux laboratoire
spécialisés procède à l'excavation des
deux cercueils
de l'ADN est prélevé sur les eaux des
deux défuntes afin de les comparer et de
voir si elles sont bien mère et fille
pour les formats c'est une humiliation
[Musique]
voilà
un des anciens de la tribu nous a dit
déterrer la
ce n'est qu'un sac d'os
penser que quelqu'un peut violer votre
intimité à ce point
c'est bestial c'est inhumain
c'est contre les croyances des tribus
dans notre tradition il faut respecter
les morts et les laisser reposer en paix
[Musique]
les formats n'ont reçu les résultats du
test ADN
les conclusions des deux laboratoires
indépendants sont sans appel
[Musique]
s
concluent qu'il y avait
99,89 % de chances qu'elle soit mère et
fille selon les standards scientifiques
américains
pourquoi
c'est une bonne question
tout ça c'est à cause de l'argent et de
la cupidité il ne respectent rien ni
personne
vous savez quand vous expulsez une
grosse partie de la tribu en
l'occurrence 30% avec notre famille
c'est 30% de dividendes des casinos en
plus pour ceux qui ne sont pas virés
c'est évident que l'argent est à
l'origine de tout cela
et combien vous perceviez par mois à
l'époque
c'était 3000 dollars par mois et par
personne et maintenant les membres
restants de la tribu touchent 5 à 6000
dollars par mois
en fait notre tribu nous fait subir ce
que le gouvernement américain nous a
fait subir il y a quelques années quand
il nous éliminé
exactement la même chose il nous élimine
ils n'ont pas le droit ce n'est pas
juste
le gouvernement fédéral des États-Unis
et aujourd'hui on lutte contre notre
propre tribu je croyais dans le cadre de
leur Sauveur NT ce sont les chefs
tribaux qui fixent les règles
d'appartenance à la tribu
nous avons fait de multiples demandes
pour rencontrer les chefs des ridings
toutes ont été refusées
nous décidons d'aller frapper à leur
porte en laissant tourner discrètement
la caméra nous souhaitons savoir
pourquoi les résultats ADN des formats
ont été rejetés le frère de la chef à
son explication
quand ils ont fait le test ADN
ils ont pas utilisé la bonne méthode
scientifique
en plus ils ont envoyé directement les
résultats du laboratoire chez eux
ils auraient dû les faire parvenir
d'abord à la tribu le processus n'a pas
été respecté
le test ADN n'était pas bon allez ta
gueule tu dégages maintenant
ok visiblement nos questions dérangent
un peu plus loin nous tombons sur un
autre membre de la tribu un peu plus
loquace
moi je faisais partie des gens qui
voulaient que les formats ne soient pas
expulsés parce qu'ils ont toujours été
considérés comme membre de la tribu
mais il y a beaucoup de jeunes et eux
l'ont certainement fait pour l'argent
vous vous êtes membre de la tribu
donc maintenant vous touchez plus
d'argent puisqu'il y a moins de membres
oui c'est vrai nous avons plus d'argent
il y a toujours la même somme à partager
alors comme nous sommes moins nombreux
nous avons une plus grosse part du
gâteau
vous pourriez nous le dire en interview
cela
ne se fait pas de parler contre sa tribu
les expulsions c'est le nouveau mal des
Indiens d'Amérique aujourd'hui ils sont
près de 3000 à avoir été banni de leur
tribu
être expulsé cela veut dire tout perdre
assurance maladie bourse d'études
dividendes des casinos mais c'est
surtout perdre son identité un des
racines en supportables pour beaucoup
d'indiens
toujours dans le nord de la Californie à
2h de route des reading la tribu des
Robinson rancheria 300 membres et son
inévitable casino
[Musique]
histoire s'écrit au présent plus de 70
personnes sont sur le point de se faire
bannir par leur conseil tribal
Marion Kutti quitte fait partie des
Robinson rancheria depuis toujours comme
le prouve sa carte de membre de la tribu
mais il y a quelques semaines le Conseil
tribal lui envoie cette lettre
ça c'est une lettre du Conseil tribal
concernant le processus de bannissement
il est écrit que je vais bientôt ne plus
être membre de la tribu
selon le Conseil tribal sa mère Marie
bogue a été enrôlée dans la tribu par
erreur il y a près de 100 ans Marion et
sa femme ont tous les documents prouvant
le contraire
c'est un document du Bureau des Affaires
indiennes de 1928 le grand-père de
Marion le père de sa mère l'a sur la
photo a bien été enregistré comme un
indien de Californie avec ses enfants
la mère de Marion est enregistrée ici
cela prouve qu'elle est indienne que
Marianne est indien chez wazen que toute
la famille est indienne
problème lors du dernier recensement de
la tribu en 1965 la mère de Marion a
oublié de se faire enregistrer
aujourd'hui le Conseil tribal exploite
cet oubli pour expulser Marion et 70
parents un cinquième de la tribu
là aussi une histoire d'argent mais pour
Marianne le problème n'est pas là
comment faites-vous pour savoir qui vous
êtes
d'où vous venez
l'argent tout cela ce n'est pas
important
S qui ont vécu toutes ces années ici
c'est vraiment traumatisant
pour moi c'est extrêmement dur
ma mère était membre de la tribu je suis
son fils
et on est obligé de vivre tout cela
toute la famille était d'ici
elle était encore là elle aimerait que
je m'occupe de cette affaire comme on
faisait à l'époque c'est à dire
en combattant je suis très énervé
ici aussi toutes nos demandes
d'interview avec les responsables de la
tribu ont été refusés
nous décidons d'aller directement chez
la chef tribal
elle nous répond cachée derrière la
porte
pourquoi avez-vous expulsé des membres
de la tribu pourquoi vous me posez cette
question ça ne vous regarde pas pourquoi
parce que je m'intéresse juste à cette
histoire voilà écoutez il y a plusieurs
tribus qui ont déjà fait ça c'est un
problème interne ça ne regarde personne
d'autre
vous pourriez ouvrir la porte s'il vous
plaît non je ne peux pas et je ne le
ferai pas si vous ne partez pas
maintenant je vous fais arrêter pour
violation de propriété privée
si vous filmez sur notre permission on
appellera nos avocats et la police
locale si on veut on peut vous
confisquer votre matériel
mais les gens disent que vous êtes je me
fous de ce que les gens disent
ok chérie appelle la police appelle là
maintenant
face à leur tribu les expulsés n'ont
aucun recours juridique
tout ce qui leur reste c'est d'investir
la rue pour se faire entendre du reste
de l'Amérique
atémicoula dans le sud de la Californie
une cinquantaine d'Indiens expulsés de
six tribus de la région sont venus
manifester leur colère
[Musique]
merci créateur pour nous avoir tous
réunis ici
je prie pour que nos voix résonnent
jusqu'à Washington
je sais que la victoire est proche pour
tous ceux d'entre nous qui ont été
victimes et dont les droits ont été
violés
ok merci créateur
selon la tradition indienne les ancêtres
sont honorés pour se protéger avant le
combat
car tous ces manifestants sont en lutte
mais contre leur propre tribu
à la tête de ce combat John Gomez il y a
5 ans lui aussi a été expulsé de sa
tribu depuis il a créé une association
pour essayer d'empêcher les expulsions
d'abandonner
pour John Gomez et les manifestants les
expulsions ne sont pas qu'un problème
d'indien elle concerne toute l'Amérique
car selon eux ce sont les droits
civiques qui sont bafoués
[Applaudissements]
les tribus font ce qu'elles veulent
elles Bafou nos droits civiques elle se
sépare même des anciens
et cela est inacceptable aux États-Unis
mais d'une certaine façon il nous
élimine il change notre statut et nous
ne sommes plus considérés comme des
Indiens par le gouvernement fédéral
pour les manifestants les expulsions
sont arbitraires mais aucune autorité
américaine ne veut s'emparer de ses
dossiers
même le Bureau des Affaires indiennes à
Sacramento c'est l'agence fédérale
responsable de la question des Indiens
aux États-Unis
quand des Indiens se font expulser de
leur tribu généralement on n'est pas mis
au courant on ne nous donne pas les
raisons de ces décisions cela est géré
en interne par les tribus
suprême nous interdit d'intervenir
les questions d'appartenance à une tribu
c'est probablement l'un des pouvoirs les
plus sacrés des Indiens d'Amérique
tout cela est lié à leur souveraineté
qui puisse faire quelque chose c'est le
Congrès des États-Unis qui allait plein
pouvoir
faire changer la loi au Congrès c'est ce
qui espère bien obtenir ce jour-là John
Gomez le leader des Indiens expulsé des
tribus
après plusieurs années de combat
accompagné de son avocat John a réussi à
obtenir un rendez-vous Capitole avec une
députée du Congrès américain
représentante démocrate de Californie
très proche du président Bama une femme
sensible à la question des Indiens
elle s'appelle Diana Watson ils espèrent
bien la convaincre de faire bouger les
choses
[Musique]
les droits de l'homme c'est plus
important que tout même en cas de crise
économique
ça pourrait même être encore plus
important maintenant qu'il y a la crise
John Gomez bonjour content de vous
rencontrer asseyez-vous
une des raisons pour lesquelles nous
sommes ici avec John c'est qu'il a été
banni de sa tribu et il a
en fait on s'est rendu compte qu'en
Californie et ailleurs les expulsions
étaient liées à la corruption des chefs
tribaux elles ne veulent pas partager
vous savez en Californie il y a près de
25 tribus qui ont banni des Indiens
depuis l'expansion des casinos
la loi c'est la loi
personne ne peut y échapper
on pourrait écrire une noire qui dirait
qu'aucune aide publique ne sera versée
au tribus qui font de la discrimination
vers leur membre
je ne sais pas mais on pourrait faire
quelque chose comme cela
la députée évite convaincue elle promet
d'évoquer la question avec le ministre
de la Justice
vous savez la cupidité c'est une chose
terrible
les tribus qui sont propriétaires des
gros casinos et qui ont fait beaucoup
d'argent ne veulent pas partager avec
leurs membres
nous disons que cela ne peut pas se
passer comme ça pas dans ce pays
pourquoi pas dans ce pays
parce que les États-Unis sont censés
garantir unité justice et égalité pour
tout le monde
c'est difficile de garantir cela avec la
souveraineté des Indiens
ils se servent de la souveraineté en
disant que le gouvernement des
États-Unis n'a aucun droit pour
déterminer qui est membre ou non d'une
tribu mais nous on dit que ce n'est pas
une histoire de souveraineté
vous ne pouvez pas ignorer la
Constitution
vous savez Barack Obama s'est engagée à
combattre les injustices dans ce pays en
discuter à y réfléchir
c'est le bon moment pour agir
merci désormais la balle est clairement
dans le camp des députés et du président
Obama
merci beaucoup
mais le problème des Indiens expulsé
loin d'être résolu le Congrès américain
légifère très rarement au sujet des
tribus indiennes la dernière fois
c'était il y a plus de 20 ans